hi guys so I got a special surprise for
you I have a friend a real friend really
her name is Dax Dutch she's from text
world but she's actually you Dutch yes
she just been down in London for the
past week and it's been fun seeing as
she's in London I thought how could I
introduce the London spirit into her and
we thought what better way to do this
than to eat Harry Potter jelly beans
we're going to do the Harry Potter jelly
bean challenge which I've been looking
forward to
I haven't if you haven't seen hypo so
which if you haven't then why haven't
you and just loads of different jelly
beans some of them really lovely candy
floss cherry then you've also got vomit
that little gun Professor Dumbledore
favourite earwax so we're just gonna
take one at random and see what we get
and we've been living on the vaccine
which one's about yeah I did you cheated
I did okay to solve this problem we
won't look at the at the beans to see
whether it's an Ikea color or not okay
we'll just close our eyes pick one and
then eat it so scared okay I got light
green with speckles damn I love booger
are you definitely booger right that's
pretty good it's watermelon the puter is
not bad just maybe I swear I don't tell
you like I got a growl speckles I got a
white one this one looks promising
it does
this one tastes like we would put your
hey fits pretty good
mine was soap really yeah it was kind of
weird but I kind of like I got a
relative it was special oh yeah I got a
cherry look I guess know what it is oh
my god you have to worm okay no I was
kind of tasting the dirt which was
tasting pretty good so doesn't really
this is just proving that we like weird
weird things
pretty gross though
not three in a row I've got a light
green one and a like real oh it's
pickles which you had earlier and it
wasn't good so I was like yeah
I don't know if - spice to make it or
not I think I have a booger - oh I'm
eating grass I don't like the I like
give it to me huh this is not good give
me not good dirt grass don't lie to me
yeah it actually has the same
consistency of a booger I knew I get
this one eventually I hate cinnamon I
love cinnamon when its own things but if
it's in the jellybean blah this one
tastes pretty good
that's been it it's banana Oh blue what
do you have I have a yellow like a light
yellow with dark I know what it is if
you like to that you're already weird
it's not an egg nor did lemon
no it's does it not taste like terrible
no this is making me go down in
confidence like I'm Cerner fuel broken
like I feel weird now like oh wow this
one is a light green light green I have
I don't know what's this like
pink with gray speckles pink brown in
charcoal purple I think this is like poo
or something
Oh gross Oh sausage it's a sausage I
know I don't even like supposed to do
your life I have grass Oh mom well that
sausage is disgusting in Russia stays
like jellybean pink with yellow speckles
Oh Oh
tutti frutti mm-hmm it's kind of that
one I have white so do I we have to say
Monica okay let's go through this
together
yes I think this is - yeah let's see if
you like it Alex
I don't like down and that you could go
to candy shop and buy a stick of wood
that you can eat like yeah it's kind of
like edible would go right where she
lives right
jazz chocolate sprinkles on bread for
breakfast and then when she wants a
snack she just eats would don't go over
that anyway meantime Oh crazy speckles
like great whisper girls all right Oh
mom this is disgusting
there's a Peppa it tastes just like
Peppa hmm this was not very good either
mmm wha it's through ground okay I got
booger again you've got you got black
pepper that's supposed to be good why is
it supposed to be kids not it just says
like you know my head Peck you don't
like pipe are you two like cinnamon yeah
but I like Mugur dark green reddish okay
that was weird
I've got um red with dark speckles
really gross by the way okay
oh man this is not good how could you
like earthworm this is our firm oh
you're like me I think this one was
watermelon I don't like it though have
you tried to know so I know I've had a
lot less yeah I don't think I've had
green apple each away let's eat the nice
one really
even the good ones together with the bat
once they just ended up all bad cut it
bad I think they got worse as it went on
because the first albums weren't too bad
right then like when you add the other
bands on it was just like my mouth feels
like lightly not good all we know from
that we learned that high positive
jellybeans aren't actually too bad at
first but then when you add on flavor
after flavor it just gets worse and
worse whereas and then oddly enough we
found out that you prefer a thrombus
being Apple yeah
and I've read Booga to cinnamon so we're
kind of weird only oh yeah it was cool
getting our Harry Potter on I'm talking
about any weapon you're just trying to
piece thank you for inserting I'm the
cool t-rex okay thank you for inserting
a love of London inside you're welcome
I'm gonna go father now
we also did another collab over on DX
doctors channel you can click on her
face over that we did an accent an
accent challenge we play with American
and British accents and she tells me
British slang and I have to guess what
it all means so it's fun so you should
definitely check it out if you feel like
it if you wanna do it give me a thumbs
up if you like this video I hope you
have a lovely day or evening bye bye
videos hit you've all been waiting for
I'm gonna open Martha's mystery box I'm
so excited to the openness and see
what's in
at the bar